germany's foreign minister says the
country is now ready to support an
embargo of russian oil imports as part
of a new sanctions package a measure it
has thus far resisted
eu members are keen to end fossil fuel
imports from russia more than two months
into the war however they've only been
able to sanction coal
germany is one of the country's most
dependent on russian oil and gas the
government has warned however that fuel
embargoes are likely to push up consumer
prices
now here's what german foreign minister
annaleina berbach had to say about an
oil embargo
we're pushing within the eu to quit
russian oil together as europeans in the
eu's sanctions
package we're setting it up in such a
way that we can stick to this for the
coming years
the sanctions will stand until
international law has been obeyed in
every way and that means russian troops
have been pulled out of ukraine
i'm joined now by claudia kempfert she's
an economist with the german institute
for economic research in berlin claudia
thanks as always for coming on to the
show it's often said that oil is
especially damaging to russia that is an
oil ban would be especially damaging to
russia
why is that and can we sort of quantify
to what extent that's true
yeah i mean that's true because
russia is very dependent on the income
of the oil is selling and that is the
largest part of the of the income they
get so the revenues are very very high
we saw that at least in the in the last
two months
europe has paid over 60 billion for only
for the import of oil and gas from
russia so on the other side russia is
very dependent on this income and gets
the largest part from the oil exports
and this is why i think it's a valuable
sanction and will it will hurt russia as
well
at the same time it's likely to hurt
here locally when we look at prices now
of course this is a different kind of
damage when we talk about you know in
the aspect of an entire war but local
prices will rise that's what the economy
minister said today is that something
that consumers here
are willing to put up with do you think
what kind of a shock could this be for
them
well of course the oil price will
increase because of such kind of embargo
but it's also increasing because of the
war and it's uh it should be our
interest to to increase the chance that
the war is at least ending
very soon so this is why such kind of
embargo is important but of course there
will be a steep price increases and we
already saw them and this will increase
further and that means also gasoline
prices will increase and the government
is already in germany is reacting in
other countries as well to help
consumers by paying a certain amount of
money but also by reducing the gasoline
price which is our to our opinion the
wrong way because we should support the
energy saving and not the energy
consuming
but on the other hand of course we have
to go this way we could not deal make
further deals with russia and that's why
important to to go for this kind of
embargo why has it taken why has it
taken germany this long to become
comfortable with an oil embargo
compared to a number of other eu member
states
well obviously there is a there is a
larger amount of oil imports coming from
russia over 35 percent and we have a
special situation in eastern part of
germany where the direct pipeline from
russia is landing in that's the joshua
pipeline but that's also valuable for
for poland so they had to prepare
obviously and get other sources and
diversify the oil imports which they now
did and we can buy germany can buy
oil from other countries there is enough
oil on the market and now they have
prepared and now they are prepared and
they go for this oil embargo and that's
that's a good strategy
all right claudia kempford with the
german institute for economic research
in berlin thank you very much
thank you
you